[Musica]
e quando io immagino il futuro
io sono un astrofisico e quindi quando
pensa al futuro penso al tempo anzi
siamo perversi allo spazio tempo ad
einstein e il tempo è relativo anche il
futuro è relativo
chi vive in alta montagna o chi vive al
livello del mare
per loro il tempo passa diversamente e
quindi avranno un differente futuro e si
grazie a qualche miliardesimo di secondo
ma guardate che se voi non considerate
questo differente futuro il gps non
funziona e gps cosa fa confronta il
tempo dei satelliti gps e il tempo
vostro e sono diversi e da quella
diversità se non la correggete andate
tutti fuori strada e vi perdete quindi è
importante questa differenza di futuro
poi se voi andate sempre più velocemente
il tempo per voi passa più lentamente
fino ad arrivare alla velocità della
luce dove il tempo si ferma un raggio di
luce vive in un eterno presente può
nascere può morire ma la sua vita è
sempre un adesso e questo è strano per
noi abituati a annua da piccole velocità
e neanche tante forza di gravità se
siete su un buco nero vedreste il futuro
dell'universo passare in un istante e
voi siete un istante e avete visto il
futuro allora ha senso parlare di futuro
molti fisici teorici pensano che non ci
sia neanche il futuro il tempo non
esiste in fondo alle particelle
subatomiche il tempo non serve forse
solo una nostra illusione un nostro modo
di percepire la realtà che ordiniamo con
il prima e con il dopo ma a questo punto
se non ha senso ma c'è altra parola
quando immagini il futuro immaginazione
creatività fantasia e adesso dovrei
parlare di musica
no no no parliamo di scienza perché uno
non pensa queste tre facoltà legate a
uno
il fiato in realtà si quando uno pensa
una nuova terio intanto la deve
inventare e poi per verificare se giusta
cosa deve fare deve vedere qualcosa
prevedere un fenomeno prevedere vedere
prima immaginare che deve prevedere un
fenomeno e poi se quel fenomeno si
realizza e gli altri non l'avevano
previsto lui c'ha ragione questa sua
teoria diventa scienza quindi gli
scienziati immaginano inventano creano è
vero fino a 800 la meccanica di i fisici
pensavano che non ci fosse più niente da
inventare
bastava conoscere con precisione le
condizioni iniziali di un sistema cioè
posizione e velocità
cose normali di tutte le particelle
tutto era prestabilito il futuro era già
predeterminato dal passato c'era solo
applicare le equazioni finita
non c'è nient'altro da fare ma
l'universo non funziona così
passati pochi decenni si è scoperto che
non si può misurare la posizione e la
velocità di una particella
contemporaneamente c'è un'incertezza
sempre l'incertezza entra nella
meccanica geniale sta cosa e quindi
l'universo deve basarsi sull'incertezza
e quindi quando io parto e penso al
futuro di un evento poiché non ho più la
precisione posso pensare infiniti futuri
possibili alcuni sono più probabili
altri meno ma sempre possibili e quindi
posso solo parlare di probabilità e nel
momento in cui qualcosa succede
ecco questo evento mi cancella tutti i
futuri che non lo prevedevano ma ne apre
infiniti altri
da lì in poi è un nuovo inizio in fondo
è sempre un nuovo inizio
io vedo il futuro come un nuovo inizio
visto che così dice fisica un nuovo
inizio che è cominciato per me
astrofisico quando la prima volta che
l'uomo ha guardato le stelle belle
fantastico stai li guardi l'impari ti
ritornano tutti gli anni sono le stesse
le riconosci
però loro sono sempre un po lontane no
noi cresciamo moriamo loro no eterne
superiori sono sopra sono divine allora
l'uomo ha cominciato a inventarsi delle
storie metterci degli animali sono nate
così le costellazioni l'orsa il leone lo
scorpione mettere qualcosa della propria
vita in quel cielo farlo un po più
familiare un po più nostro e quindi ha
cambiato il cielo un nuovo inizio per il
cielo un nuovo cielo e non è bastato
perché a un certo punto è arrivata la
fisica
certo non posso prendere una stella
metterà sul tavo il laboratorio
sezionarla tagliarla a studiarla farne
una diversa no questo non lo posso fare
l'astrofisico ma posso studiare la luce
che mi arriva da quella stella e mi dà
tantissimo informazioni ma proprio tante
ad esempio quanto è vasto le stelle
ntato sempre più grande e uno parlava
l'universo vi potrei dire miliardi di
miliardi di miliardi di chilometri ma
noi non concepiamo numeri vero sono
astronomici numeri di quella taglia
dobbiamo inventarci un qualcosa di
diverso il m funziona in questa stanza
funziona per i mobili già in auto usiamo
i km e migliaia di chilometri con gli
aerei allora forse basta trovare il m
giusto beh m universale anche libri core
ad einstein la velocità della luce nel
vuoto è la stessa per tutti tutti
misurano quei famosi 300.000 chilometri
al secondo chilometro più km meno per
una velocità e se vogliono a distanza
300.000 chilometri al secondo
in un secondo 300mila chilometri che una
distanza così si inventa e secondo luce
che è una distanza enorme quasi otto
volte giro della terra in un secondo fa
la luce quasi la distanza terra luna in
un secondo il secondo luce è grande però
se guardiamo l'universo il sole quanto
dista non bastano i secondi 8 minuti
luce e il confine il sistema solare
plutone più di cinque ore e la stella
più vicina quattro anni luce allora la
misura non è secondo luce la l'unità di
misura è l'anno
l'hanno luce questo il minimo tutte le
stelle che vediamo in cielo stanno 100
mila anni luce
però sono la stelle della nostra
galassia e le altre galassie andromeda
la più vicina 2 milioni di anni luce
vi faccio capire cos'è 2 milioni di anni
luce avete cellulare tutti io voglio
chiamare il mio amico che è su andromeda
c'è un amico la allora prefisso
intervallati co
va bene costa un capitale ma oggi ne
vale la pena
pp ppp e dopo 2 milioni di anni suona ma
il mio amico della terra pronto
altri due milioni di anni è un po lenta
e pensate se trovate l'utente chiamata
al momentaneamente occupato si prega di
chiamare più di questo è blanda galassie
più vicina la luce che si arriva da più
lontano arriva da qualcosa come quasi 14
miliardi di anni luce
però vi do un segreto
se io guardo andromeda e la luce ci ha
messo due milioni di anni arrivare da me
vuol dire che non sto vedendo andromeda
come adesso ma come era 2 milioni di
anni fa e se guardo una luce che partita
13 miliardi di anni fa
sto vedendo inverso giovane aveva solo
400 mila anni più guardo lontano nello
spazio più guardo indietro nel tempo è
così che noi astrofisici ricostruiamo
l'evoluzione dell'universo universo che
fatto da 2 300 miliardi di galassie noi
100 miliardi 200 mila di meno la stessa
ogni galassia fatta da 2 300 miliardi di
stelle ma su una di queste galassie via
lattea e su una stella di questa grasse
il sole e su un pianeta intorno a questa
stella c'è qualcuno che prova a
conoscere come fatto questo immenso
universo ed hinton era uno scienziato
astronomo dell'inizio a 900 ha detto che
l'uomo che tempi di conoscere l'universo
visto cosa è piccolo rispetto a quello è
un po come il parassita di una patata
chiusa in un sacco nella stiva di una
nave che da come viene sballottato cerca
di capire come fatto l'oceano questo è
il nostro ruolo ma è bello è che questo
parassita ci riesce
qualcosa riesce a capire dell'universo e
perché perché l'uomo è fatto della
stessa materia di cui sono fatte le
stelle il big bang origine universo ha
prodotto idrogeno tantissimo bel po di
elio ok pochino di litio e tracce di
perilli allora da dove vengono azoto
ossigeno carbonio ferro manganese tutti
gli elementi che compongono le nostre
cellule che compongono noi non dal big
bang non dall'inizio l'universo si sono
formate all'interno di una stella che
poi è esplosa e ha disseminato il suo
materiale in giro per l'universo in un
altra parte universo si è formato il
sole arricchito di questo materiale con
un pianeta arricchito di questo
materiale
e su questo pianeta noi quindi noi siamo
fatti di stelle
allora forse come le stelle abbiamo un
compito cosa fa una stella mastella
splende la stella da luce da calore e
allora anche tutti noi fatti di stelle
abbiamo forse un compito dare luce e
calore agli altri questo è quello che io
penso quando immagina il futuro un
raggio di luce quindi in un eterno
presente ma per gli altri
imparate dal passato vivete il presente
ma sognate per l'avvenire
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]